taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man they taste buddies it's
the taste
buds you know i don't like to just call
it podcast it's a show
that's the show it's a it's a prime time
show yeah welcome network prime time
that's what i see it
as that's how yes
that's joe there you go you're not good
at an improv troupe
like a gun uh real quick
shout outs to zarface and
uh esoteric for sending me the tsar face
gear
i posted about this starface one of my
favorite rap groups what's esoteric
meaning esoteric is a rapper
oh it was out of context so i didn't
know exactly
they're great you should listen to them
it's it's inspector deck from wu-tang
and esoteric
yeah and dj7l when you were saying it i
didn't know what the context was
now i get it yeah so he sent me this
shirt plus a copy of the new album
and i'm wearing it on the show nice
thank you
right and also do my part to help maybe
this helps push the album a little bit
all right very nice great it's with mf
doom it's like they did it before he
passed
wow so it's it i think i well i don't
know if it's the last thing enough doom
did or not but it's a really really
great album
it's funny because i was looking for a
t-shirts away to help promote something
as well i'm not even joking around
couldn't find it
through on my own mike tyson shirt
mm-hmm which i made myself don't steal
my idea
yeah but i was looking for my red seal
gaming shirt because i want to shout out
red seal gaming
which is a specialty game store uh that
my cousin owns
uh it's going well they have a little
community there they do dungeons and
dragons and they're doing a podcast now
and i'm gonna sit in i've been wanting
to do this my whole life i'm going to
sit in
and play some dungeons and dragons for
the first time my entire
life soon i always wanted to do that too
did you ever do it no
we should go you should come with me can
i crash this thing i don't see why not i
think they would love to have us they
love they're huge fans of the podcast i
would love to come to it yes so we're
serious i've always wanted to do this
but the friends i had that played it
were too advanced and
i i felt tense you guys are doing this
are advanced but they're like
they'll nurture us a little well two of
them are my cousins and they like uh
dave no this will be right up around
this is the way to do it okay great i
don't know i don't know
although all the hubbub is i feel like i
might like it if it's just like really
fun
and like you know just like just it's
kind of like playing poker or something
just like getting to bs and like make
stuff
have you ever played pimp d and d uh no
but i have a lot of friends who love
that
really yeah and these are like 30 years
or something like that
i feel it really comes down to a good
dungeon master that's right
so i hear yeah well i'm interested to
get a taste
uh speaking of taste bud
today just bring the heat just bring
that heat
today's
made me laugh today's battle
spare ribs versus fried chicken yeah
well i listen to this
spare ribs and ribs the same thing yeah
i can't you know
i don't know you tell me if somebody's
going to nitpick over ribs versus spare
i don't i wouldn't even know this is i
call them ribs this is a
huge i'd say out of all the 27 30
episodes we've had so far
fried chicken and ribs are
you hear that fried chicken and ribs
are two powerhouse foods so this is a
this is a marquee match-up today this is
and again
kicking off a beautiful and i you know i
hope we can kind of stick with this
because i'm just thinking of it now in
the podcast i'm sure it's nothing we've
discussed
okay uh but i'm noticing
our kickoff episodes for june uh
well actually it's sort of like the
second week of june moving forward as we
enter
real summer hot girl summer thought
summer
uh what did you say the last thing was a
thought summer it sounds like you're
saying
thought yeah thought that hoe over there
thought
you never heard that yes what is thought
oh thought yeah oh okay it sounds like
you're saying
t-h-o-u-g-h-t okay
have you been have you been saying
thought in conversation i always
pronounced this thought
ah people might not know what you're
talking about that's they do
it they're probably thinking about like
you're thinking of something they do
look confused at the club
uh no but here's the thing isn't it it's
weird to say that thought that thought
over there because that
thought thought already means that that
hoe over there
so he's saying that thought over there
there's a lot of that
that i didn't say that thought over
there oh what'd you say i said thought
girl summer
oh i'll thought girl is dark girl sounds
like you're just talking about
like thoughtful women i don't remember
what the hell i said i remember one time
i didn't know a pigeon head is that a
chicken head
chicken i didn't know i just thought
chicken head like you know when you hear
something the very first time
you just take the context you heard it
and be like oh it just means like
i don't know what but it just means like
you know like and i
remember one time i was at work and i
said something about something ah just
she's just a chicken head
and then and then someone was like a
girl i know was like what did you say
and i said god like a chicken head like
i don't know like i scrub i thought i
guess it was like a scrub
like how guys are scrubs yeah because at
that time that was a song it was like i
don't want no scrubs and then those guys
yeah they made an a a response song that
said we don't want no chicken yeah
something like that yeah
so chicken head you know what it means
the skeezer yeah but you know why it's
chicken head oh no
because the chicken barbs its head
which she looks like
oral uh oh uh-huh i'm teaching you
something now
oh sorry you turned into paul ryser for
a minute i didn't know what was going on
because i got people of all ages believe
me
but i get like i hear all the time and
people listen to it so i don't really
want to go too
too you know into whatever it's just
like i didn't maybe that's why mad about
you was so successful that's right this
is how he played it that's right babe
eight seasons chicken heads but what i
was gonna say
is is this is the second episode in this
june
where we are kicking it we're kicking
into high gear with a straight up
summer foods battle that's right okay
last week was lobster roll versus crab
cake
this week in fact first week of june was
snow caps razor nets which really was
the battle of the movie theater candies
which is a big summertime activity
blockbusters now we did then we did uh
the crab cake versus lobster roll last
week now we're doing ribs versus
chicken dude fried chicken holy [ __ ]
this is heavy this is massive
this is heavy this is massive uh i will
say right out of the gate
we have talked on the show about fried
chicken before we have both agreed the
kfc is the all-time reigning fast food
champion
uh or our favorite right you know um
which is why we didn't battle
original rests it's the only way dude
i like extra crispy i don't mind extra
crispy but i'll get chicken i'll get
like a chicken little for the extra
crispy you know
yeah chicken littles are so good dude
holy [ __ ]
how about that kfc mash i love instant
mashed potatoes
i didn't know why i like them better
dudes sometimes i
buy the box of the hungry jack at the
store i know
and i was doing that during the pandam
and my friend was going
what do you have to do just make mashed
potatoes from scratch i was like
i don't want to no it's not as fun why
are they not as good as instant mashed
potatoes i don't know
why are regular mashed potatoes exactly
made from real potatoes
not as good as instant measurements made
from fake potatoes you're gonna draw
that heinz gravy
just pour it on do you rip the skin off
the chicken and dip it into the gravy
and mashed potatoes i absolutely do
yeah i dip my chicken right in there i
do that too
you know what else i used to do was i
just dip french fries into the mashed
potatoes and gravy you can see that
potato into potato that's
it yeah i call it a speed ball
really i had a joke about it where i
said i called a speed ball but like no i
would i would i would take the potato
wedges back when they had potato wedges
well they don't have them anymore they
just have fries now get out of here
with the wedges yeah but the skinny
fries are amazing because they're just
regular fries seasoned like the potato
wedges
really they're really good okay so
anyway we've talked about fried chicken
you got some stones on you today though
because you're going well you're going
ribs you said that you didn't think you
could defend ribs i love fried chicken
but i
i can tell you i love i love ribs
so i know i can defend ribs i've had
ribs where i really enjoy them i i can
appreciate a rib i like a good rib
but most of my life i was rib adverse i
don't think i have a palate for it when
i was younger
and then when i got older and i had
really good ribs i'm like okay this is
good
but i mean let's be honest with each
other now
fried chicken is the king
of possibly the king of all comfort
foods
ever well yeah but we're not arguing
comfort food
but i'm just saying this thing this
thing walks around like who he is the
fried chicken
you know what i mean look i like the
fried the fried chicken i mean
you're getting up there into like pizza
territory
things like that i would argue i would
argue that ribs are right there with it
uh you get a perfect barbecued chinese
spare rib there's nothing like it
you go to an amazing southern barbecue
restaurant and get pork true
bit the big ribs the north
carolina-style ribs
uh nice they fall off the bone any sauce
or just a rub
um a beef rib a pork rib i
i mean ribs are just insanity speaking
of bone though
i do have a little bit of issue with the
rib bone
like when you get a rack and it's
literally just like you're looking at
someone's rib cage
someone i couldn't care less yeah
something about that rib bone
it's pretty girthy and and and it really
feels like a
bone from a body from like a skeleton in
like a biology class
and when that meat falls right off the
bone and you just i mean don't get me
wrong but usually
chicken you don't necessarily like
let's say a chicken breast or something
you don't necessarily devour it
to the point where like it's almost like
a flintstone bone the rib bone
here's what i like about it it is it is
it is a little bit
i have problems with bones and food if i
get my head if my if i get my wrap my
head around it sometimes even in chicken
but the rib bone is really prominent
because you see the rack
so now you're imagining a rib cage and
then you suck that thing off and you're
holding this thick it's almost like a
like literally like a it's got some
weight on it it feels like you put it
through your nose that's what i like
about the ribbon
like uh like the flintstones here's what
i like about the rib bone
it's a clean bone chicken bone you're
dealing with a lot of ins and outs man
you're getting the little splintery
things that hang off of it
still true there's some mean uh gristle
that that in the nooks and crannies it
hides from you
and then you got the stuff on the ends
that you're expecting you get a rib bone
it's one bone it's one piece that meat
comes right off it's clean as hell
you toss it aside you're done yeah when
you have the perfect rib bite but what
about
those ribs too that also had the
blubbery fat on them
and now you're getting the bone plushie
just chewing on this
basically the chewing gum i say this
with all
seriousness not just to win you don't
eat the fat do you
i ate the gristle i hate the fat and
then you don't sell the sizzle
you sell the steak uh no pork fat is the
most
delicious thing but you'll check too
you'll chew the blubber
yes you'll chew the blood at all and
then you swallow the blood yeah and i
eat the gristle too
does your body decompose the blubber
mine does
can't speak for anybody else so you'll
be chewing on a chunk of fat
and it doesn't break down you know it
does break down it does absolutely
breaks down
maybe i haven't done it long enough yeah
no it breaks right down it's fat
and you just swallow when you eat a
steak you don't you never eat the fat
with the meat maybe if it's marbled in
there but that big
fat on the end that just looks like a
congealed
mucus yeah i'm not saying if you put a
rack of
ribs in front of me and there was all
the fat in one place
i would rip it off
you were making a case for the very
clean bone
yeah i'm saying like a lot of times on
ribs i'll go and i'll rip it off and
then
and in the end there's all that blubber
no i i think you're using blubber wrong
first of all but there's there's some
fat on the meat how am i losing blubber
wrong
isn't blubber facts blubber is what
comes out of a whale
you know i'm using i mean i'm yeah i
mean be playing faster
sea mammals only whales and seals yeah
but i'm just
i'm being like it's a hyperbolic well
here's the thing
it's blubber it's fat fat on pork
is never a bad thing pork fat only adds
immense flavor
sometimes when i make a a spaghetti
gravy maybe you're not doing like a pie
i put pork fat into the gravy and it
dissolves in there
pork fat is delicious uh steak fat is
delicious especially on prime rib
when it's when it's part of the meal
chicken fat
is disgusting there is no there is no
scenario where
chicken fat tastes good yeah but i don't
really when i'm having fried chicken i
don't really come across too much
chicken fat
oh you do you might not notice it but
you do it's in there yeah but
you get a cheap batch of fried chicken
you're gonna have some fat okay yeah
the worst of any food's going to bring
you that but look chicken
is the most popular meat you know for a
reason
right rib meat is like maybe the least
popular meat i think no really really
when you talk about all different cuts
of steaks and meat and stuff like that
chicken is sold the most rib ribs might
be sold wait chicken's most popular
meat because everybody wants to be
healthy and eat chicken
all right there are more chickens on
earth than people
chicken is the most common type of
poultry in the world
okay well the largest serving of fried
chicken was served the kentucky fried
chicken celebration of the restaurant
oh that that last sentence just snuck in
there but but
i mean i mean saying it's the most
popular chip poultry yeah no [ __ ]
again let me ask you a question let me
answer what's
the better bite sinking into a golden
brown
crispy delicious fried perfectly
seasoned chicken breast
that is moist and bursting with
delicious juicy white meat chicken
flavor
white meat you're losing me already but
well why whatever dark meat whatever
your preference is
or you know bite it into a rib which
you know it's nice nice pork we had some
nice flavor for maybe a rub or some bbq
sauce on it
but it doesn't do
dance in your mouth that the fried
chicken fried chicken
uh i love it when i eat it i'm happy
most of the time it's pretty good
when it's bad it's real bad uh when it's
bad it almost tastes gamey or something
uh but no matter how much i want little
wings i don't mean like
what you're talking about i don't mean
wings i know about a bucket of fries i
run the gamut i run the gamut trust me
on that there's nothing like sinking
your teeth into a drumstick or a breast
right out of that bucket it's i i mean
it's wonderful i'm not saying it's not
true
when i eat a great rib when i eat a
great rib and my favorite are barbecued
chinese spare ribs
when i eat a great rib i will literally
go
after the first bite every time every
single time all right
all right look i'm gonna make a point
here right but i think it's it's
probably not the best point
but because chicken does the same thing
you'll say eat the wing eat the breast
it's the
literal they call the name of the
serving of the food
the same thing as the body part when it
was on the chicken
right so it is weird to be like have
some breast have some wing
right but something about saying have a
rib
like you know like it's not even a it's
a chicken breast or a chicken wing i get
it but like
something about saying eat the rib
is is a little bit too much for me
that's fine
but you can't focus on that you got to
get into the flavors and the taste so i
understand but i
just it just is a little bit like uh if
you just pull out a little bit
it just feel it does feel weird to be
like eat the ribs of this animal
it doesn't and you just see the rib
you're focusing
i'm telling you you're going to waste
your whole argument focusing on
something that's not going to get you
any growth
you're going to focus on so let me tell
you this let's talk about when you put
this stuff on a plate with something
else
okay because that's an important part of
it
barbecue ribs in my opinion win every
time here's why
number one you're not getting bogged
down with all the extra breading
it allows a little more room for
potentially a mac and cheese or a potato
salad or a stuffing or a heavier side
i mean you need fried chicken you're
naming sides that go with fried chicken
exclusively the best they go with ribs
too you talk about coleslaw
you're talking about cotton calls i
didn't say college
you're talking about corn i didn't say
any of those you literally just did you
hear what he just did
he named four things that i didn't say
four more i named four more but i'm
saying these are all if you go to any
soul food restaurant these are all the
it's it's it's ribs and and fried
chicken stars of the show
yeah and then these are your sides okay
so my point is this
when i get the ribs yeah how much will
rib i can i can eat
more of what i feel like is a balanced
meal because i'm not getting bogged down
with a lot of grease and a lot of
breading
i'm eating meat a little in a bit purer
of a form if you will i know but
okay and it doesn't it it doesn't make
me tired the way fried chicken does
which gives me a little more room for a
potato salad or a starchier side dish
okay but i'm not really gonna focus my
argument
on what side dishes you could have if
you if you get too full or not from the
original
i'm going clean fried chicken against
rib i also think the mixture of that
barbecue sauce on that rib
with a man-easy base side is wonderful i
love you mayo
i don't love my mayo i like it sometimes
inside
you told me on the last episode i hated
mayo ribs
are the most disgusting food to eat
hands down
you rip rib a rib when you eat ribs you
look like i didn't want to say what you
look like
you look like you're basically a human
toilet
i mean you can't eat ribs it's barbaric
you're telling me oh i love to
it doesn't fill me up it's you you don't
think [ __ ]
take the fried out of it you don't think
eating chicken off the bone is just as
barbaric no but when ribs get all over
you
when they gotta serve you wet blankets
to eat the food
they do that with chicken too i mean but
you're getting the barbecue sauce all in
your nostrils and you're
all over your cheeks so let me get this
straight you think you look
classy if you take a lady out for the
first time and you order a bucket of
fried chicken
and she's watching you munch down on our
thigh
with like the steaming bubbling juice i
didn't say i was going on a date with
someone i didn't say i was gonna order a
bucket for two people
who do i mean who am i impressing i'll
eat the ribs you get the barbecues
underneath
i'm not saying they're not messy but if
you just pick out like people eating
ribs and look at the pictures
it looks like a travesty they look like
zombies first they look like zombies
they're just feasted on them these are
ridiculous exaggerated pictures these
are ridiculous
exaggerated these are absurd just get it
looks like you got
just just your face is just every these
people are
disgusting then i've never had that much
sauce on my hands or face when i ate
ribs
how good it's like learn how to eat how
good is fried chicken
skin do you think here i am complaining
about the rib
and yet chicken fried chicken is so good
that i don't have a problem being like
i'll eat the skin of that chicken
sounds even as bad as the rib to eat
skin
yeah it's delicious it doesn't matter
it's so good i mean
you've eaten i'll peel the chicken skin
right off the fried chicken eat that
first
and then just stare at that meat and
then just bite into just the meat
without the without i
i mean it's it's undeniable i don't know
if i've ever met someone
who doesn't love fried chicken love i
said uh
no i've definitely met people that don't
like friends i love fried chicken of
course
of course how many likes
yeah i'll tell you what you go down
south you go you take yourself down to
austin texas or the like
you go into a barbecue restaurant and
i'll tell you something you ain't going
to get with fried chicken down there
right now you're not going to you're not
going to get a 12
16 hour smoked piece of meat that's
another thing it's a real arduous task
to make that
favor if you smoke them you don't have
to i'm just saying sal i'm going to
throw a few numbers at you
and i want you to tell me what's good
about that okay the number zero
the number 13 the number four
now normally you would say joe there's
nothing good about any of those numbers
zero is not a good thing 13 unlucky
four i don't know i feel a little left
out
like the fifth wheel but when you're
talking zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and four net
grams
of carbs in each serving you're talking
about magic spoon and suddenly those
numbers are beautiful yeah if you're an
adult that used to like eating cereal
but haven't done it
recently because your body is not built
to sustain the ingredients that normal
cereal
puts out then you're going to want to
look into magic spoon and if you're also
an adult like me who now reads things as
calories
uh and you've taken joy the first thing
you do i go for the nutrition field yeah
take joy and everything out of the
equation it's just a calorie number to
you at this point yeah 140 calories per
serving
but it's also delicious and it's also
fun to eat
and you get to eat cereal again what's
not to to gain from this
it's keto friendly it's gluten free it's
grain free it's soy free it's low carb
it's gmo free
everybody with all the issues you could
eat it build that way build the boxes
build the boxes you can get a cocoa
flavor fruity flavor frosted flavor
peanut butter flavor blueberry flavor
cinnamon flavor
and i have mixed these and they taste
good when you start mixing i wonder what
happens if you mix all six of those
uh i think you become a wizard
[Laughter]
honestly you heard it here first get all
six
mix them together and just tape it okay
and you post it to
hair shake taste buds magic spoon we
want to see what happens when you eat
all six flavors at once
if you become a wizard you will be our
first guest ever
and we are dead serious if you are
eating magic spoon at home and you're a
fan of the show
mix send us a video mix all six together
if you have all six
yeah we just want to see you do it well
better yet and also
rank rank your flavors that you like the
best too i swear to god though if we see
someone become a wizard
that's yeah so anyway go to magic spoon
taste buds
so anyway if you want to enter the
wizard challenge you're going to go to
magicspoon.com
taste buds and you're going to enter
promo code taste buds again that's
magicspoon.com
taste buds and you're going to enter
promo code tastebuds you're going to
save five bucks
during checkout all right you can make
your own box
you can make your own custom bundle
consistency exactly of multiple boxes
exactly and they're also this is this is
something this is why
when you hear us talk about it every
week and you're like oh i don't really
do the ad thing i listen but this is why
you should do this okay
because it is backed with a 100
guarantee that's how confident magic
spoon is if you don't like it
for any reason no questions asked
they'll refund your money so you have
literally nothing to lose you buy it you
don't like it
send it back magicspoon.com taste buds
use that promo code taste buds and
you're gonna
save five dollars thanks a lot magic
spoon
okay folks we're here to talk to you
about blue chew you may have heard of it
you may not have heard of it
uh blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients
as viagra or cialis if you're having
problems with erectile dysfunction
but it's in a chewable tablet at a
fraction of the cost that's a fraction
of the cost
but a full-size erection and can i tell
you how i would have started it
yeah not that we need to start over i
just want to tell you i would have said
it's summertime let's talk about
pitching tents
oh that's very nice yeah i know i know
yeah i know that's a little a double
entendre
yeah yeah i like that stuff you can take
them anytime day or night
you imagine you couldn't take them any
time
[Laughter]
like look you gotta take it between 12
and 1205
a.m trust us do not take them after 12
hours
you will multiply yeah uh you can take
these
any time you're safe you can take them
any time you can plan ahead if you want
uh and be ready when your opportunity
arises and what they mean by that is
is the two different versions of the
pill that they are offering i actually
like that they do this
there's one that is built more for like
sort of immediate like
here we go hot and heavy unexpectedly
not pills tablets
sorry and here's what i like about this
take them any time
uh so you can plan ahead or be ready
when everything is
they have two kinds of tablets that
they're offering
and one of the tablets is built for like
hey man this is for like if you're ready
to go in like an hour or so
unexpected hot and heavy yeah and then
the other one is like this is like
if you need to my lifestyle could you be
in it all day yeah
so i think that that's really really
cool i also think it's great that the
tablets are made in the usa
uh and they're prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discreet
package which is nice this can
be a little bit of an awkward subject
for some people sure but you're not
going to the pharmacy you don't have to
make it get
you know take an embarrassing uh
appointment with someone where you got
to talk about this stuff the process is
as simple as you can get
because you just go to bluetooth.com you
consult with a medical provider
licensed and once you're approved you
get the prescription
within you yeah pretty great pretty
great so
we want you to go do we have to do this
part
read verbate so you can benefit from the
extra confidence there it is
can you read that i can't see it sure so
if you could benefit from a little extra
confidence
and why can't we all then it's time to
okay got it ready so if you could
benefit from a little extra confidence
when it's time to perform
and who couldn't right we all can
improve only only jesus is perfect
blue chew can help we got a special deal
for our listeners
uh try blue chew free
i'm not asking you for any money they're
not asking you for anything it's free
when you use the promo code taste buds
at checkout all you do is pay for the
five dollar shipping
because we cannot control the mail
that's government run that's
bluechew.com
promo code tastebuds to receive your
first month free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
thank you bluechu for being sponsored
this is another option for your ribs you
get that smoked
thick where the pork turns pink almost
and you bite into that and the juice and
by the way not messy at all because
they're not slathered in sauce
they go in dry rub they give you sauce
on the side if you want to add it or if
you want to dip
it and you bite into that dude
what are we even talking about here what
are we even talking about i also like
the process of eating fried chicken
choosing if i want
which piece i want how big of it i won't
work it's a lot of fun where i want to
start it from i flip it around i look
where i should sink my teeth into first
i also think that fried chicken as i
mentioned it's
the number one comfort food i think
undeniably of all time but i also like
that
it's a summer food like you mentioned
those little
facts in like of yours when you go you
act like you're not saying a big thing
but you're saying a big thing and you go
you go also with fried chicken you know
i think it's
the number one cup of fruit of all time
undeniably but uh you know more
importantly
i see you doing i don't like what you do
do you protest that i do
what do you think is the number one
comfort food evolved i think you'd get a
lot of three i think you'd get a lot of
arguments for turkey pot pie or chicken
pot pie i think you get a ton of
arguments for shepherd's pie
i think you get a lot of arguments for
pizza quite frankly i don't think you
can say
undeniably the number one comfort food
is fried chicken
i'll give you pizza because that is
really i mentioned pizza at the top of
the episode i said
we're dealing with the big boys now yeah
chicken is is
is is a dominant channel but we're not
talking comfort foods we're talking
chick we're talking chicken versus rice
but i was gonna say is chicken
fried chicken is amazing at a cookout in
the summer fried chicken is also amazing
in the winter
like it's a hearty comfort food
from the cold and i got a nice plate of
fried chicken mashed potatoes gravy
corn tell me pork ribs aren't going to
make you feel the same i don't think
pork ribs have like a comfort winter
food i don't think of it that way
what i think of it as a great asian
style food i think it was a great summer
food or a bbq food
but i don't really i don't really see it
as like how do you not see southern
barbecue as comfort food
that's literally what it is no but i'm
not i'm not i'm saying i don't see it as
like a winter food
you don't know don't change it you said
comfort food
you said comfort food we're talking
about bbq is a comfort food yes
but i'm just saying i think chicken is
more versatile than a rib
oh i do and i i also why is that i also
think
why is that when two of your pieces are
going out the window right off the bat
because i think
when the breast and wing are useless
right off the bat i think because i will
tell you this too leg inside
if you just uh lined up a hundred people
and said do you eat fried chicken do you
like fried chicken
i think you're gonna get let's i'm not
gonna be ridiculous like you are
sometimes
i think you're gonna get a very high
percentage maybe in the 90s of people
that say i eat it and i love it and i'm
even including kids in that anything
but with ribs i really feel like people
are like oh i could take goalie ribs or
i don't like ribs
why is it then if they're in the same
class and you're thinking that you're
making an argument against fried chicken
why is it if you agree with me that you
wouldn't get people across the board of
100 people being like i eat and love
ribs all the time
why are ribs to me a much more selective
i don't know anybody that doesn't like
ribs i really do i i have people i know
i've tried don't like people that don't
really love ribs that it's not one of
their favorites i know a lot of people
that won't eat fried chicken based on
health alone they're like it's too
unhealthy it's deep fried it's
a lot of saturated fat there's no way
i'm going to defend fried chicken as a
health food
but i'm just defending its deliciousness
i understand but
honey yes of course fried chicken and
waffles
yeah i'm not a fan okay i do like it
with honey i do like a little honey with
it
but listen dude it's it's boneless fried
chicken
on a sandwich it's what about when
people were murdering each other in the
streets for fried chicken sandwiches
by the way two years uh somebody on
twitter has said there's no restaurant
devoted to ribs exclamation point joe
derosa 2021
thinking that i am team fried chicken
right now i was going to yell that
because i think it is a goddamn travesty
that there is no restaurant devoted to
ribs yet there are so many chicken
restaurants both fast fast casual and
upscale
yeah but you know what else i'm going to
hit you at something because you
complain
why why are there people in the streets
beating each other over fried chicken
sandwiches
why they don't do that sandwiches
but why because they're idiots but why
are there people storming the capital
because they're
idiots that's not the same people are
dumb that's not the same thing people
are
really dumb that sentence is true but
but why are people
fighting over fried chicken
because it's that good i'm gonna blow
your is it because it's that i'm gonna
blow your mind right now and you hate
when it comes into it but it's coming
into it right now
guess what's at mcdonald's all year
round different
forms of fried chicken guess what comes
around
once in a while and people lose their
[ __ ]
the mick rib
i can't believe you're gonna bring the
mick ribbon to this the mick you see how
crazy people go for it
you love bringing you you see how crazy
people are going
do you like to go like this face please
go like this see let me see if your face
comes off and you're just a a corporate
representative from mcdonald's
because you bring up mcdonald's but i'm
arguing in every single episode
arguing that the people love the mick
ripped you you there is a
frenzy for the mcgregor what's the show
with the boss
undercover boss is that you undercover
bossing me
you're you're in a in a battle am i
wrong in a battle
of ribs versus fried chicken you bring
up the mcgregor stress my point
address my point look at this if the
mcrib comes up in this debate i will
lose it
thank you because then thinking what i'm
thinking you're doing yourself
there's a reason why you asked people to
make rip carrot in front of you and you
get excited
people you ask it over the questions
they get back to you
they get batshit over the mcrib because
it's only offered once in a while and
when you
make people think something is exclusive
or limited
they want it more and there's a little
fuss around it and they need to use that
to move units of ribs once a year and
whip people into frenzy the reason fried
chicken is available in many forms all
year round
is because it is a beast it is king it
is in demand
people will not get sick of it rib on
the menu 365
next to the chicken what's going to sell
more big chicken
ribs no it's not jokes that's what i'm
saying to you more people
mcrib and by the way the thing the
sandwich you're so proud that people are
mugging each other for in the street
it's not even fred doesn't even count as
fried chicken it's a fried chicken
breast
it's boneless fried chicken no [ __ ]
horseshit
what do you mean horseshit [ __ ] is
what i mean it's still chicken that's
fried
that's fried chicken okay nobody said
bone you started this thing being like
dry rub
spare ribs okay then pulled pork counts
as ribs because it's rib meat i mean
give me a break but you know it is a
fried chicken without a bone that's all
okay
a fried okay then pulled pork
counts as rib meat because that's what
it is and pulled pork now enters the
enters the equation as one of the most
amazing sandwiches of all time
you could have went with pulled pork
sandwich versus fried chicken no you
can't use the chicken sandwich
in the fried chicken battle and you know
goddamn damn well
fried chicken sandwich pimp your take
swear to god
i would count the chicken sandwich and
the pulled pork all right so both count
no you can't declared both count you
can't count pulled pork
both counts but pulled pork is not but
i'm jo
but okay but fried chicken boneless on a
sandwich
is can taste nearly identical and
to a frog bite if you're right pulled
pork tastes so
crazy different than spare ribs i don't
understand
can i tell you something when it's so
the same when i get sparabs i won't get
pulled pork cause i go don't give me
more of the same [ __ ]
can i tell you something actually pulled
pork i i
i liked only later in life because the
first like
30 years plus of my life i i
thought that pulled pork smelled and
tasted
like wet dog do you know what dog
not personally no you don't know what
dog yes yeah i had a dog yeah
you know when the dog comes in from the
rain and he's like i understand what a
wet dog is smell them
and it smells like a wet dog give me
another example i'm not sure i'm
following
if a dog jumps in a pool or a pond
or you hose your dog down right and then
i think i think i'm grabbing
a distinct smell i swear to god i smell
the cousin of that smell when i when i
when i when i smell pulled pork and
sometimes if i let the smell get to me
i imagine that the pulled pork tastes
like what a wet dog would taste like
my mind i'm not making that argument
against herbs i'm telling you a fun
story about my life
okay why are you telling me i'm out of
my mind that's something i felt okay
but it's a passive aggressive shot at
pulled pork
pork now oh i like it now but it kind of
smells like dog but i like it i'm just
saying it took me a while to come around
to it where
chicken fingers is the first thing a
child will eat the parents are like
are they off mushy foods give them
chicken fingers
there's a reason it's still it's
delicious more people like it
it casts a bigger net there's a reason
it can't tell you this
it tastes more palatable overall than a
barbecued rib
bad fried chicken is so much worse than
bad ribs it's it's oh i don't know about
that
it's a bad rib sometimes makes me almost
want to give up ribs all together alley
cat says fried chicken it can wear so
many different hats breakfast with
waffles no problem
sandwich with crisps all you got it an
array of sauce options that will most
likely give you
spicy butthole but it's worth it because
chicken is so crispy and delicious
absolutely i mean there you go really
and i think that's going to be the same
thing
same thing goes to ribs fine find a rib
that says pork find a rip comment that
says something like that the mcrib
pulled pork you gotta stop with the mick
you gotta stop with the mick
ribs and waffles is a thing too i mean
i've never heard of it until just a
second no no no
go go ribs and waffles is not a thing go
back to the board
pimpy on the twitter pimpsicle and uh
find me a rib comment like that
ribs are more versatile with flavor and
method of cooking than fried chicken
ribs have complex flavors
they are worth the mess fried chicken on
the other hand makes you hate yourself
way too greasy in a gross way you can't
wash your hands fast enough
thank you thank you that's a valid point
that's a valid point you know what let's
just go to the polls here where are we
where are we hold on where are we where
are we time-wise we're about 30 minutes
folks i know it was a very very very
long year for everybody in 2020 and 2020
certainly spilled into 2021
a lot of stuff going on we spent a lot
of time in the house and some of us
uh probably now man probably more of us
i should say more of us than less of us
have probably formed some habits that
we'd like to maybe break or maybe you
just want to start living a little bit
better look i'm the co-host of a food
podcast
uh it's hard to not indulge all the time
it's hard to keep yourself
on track it's true and it's not just
food stuff it's everything
yeah it's everything i was i was having
a rough this is i'm not just saying this
and i want to say that because it's true
i was having a couple of rough days a
while back uh a couple weeks ago
someone actually told me have you ever
heard of noom and i was like i actually
have
i actually speak about it because they
advertise in our pockets
they're great it's making the rounds new
it's a great great
program uh i just signed up for it
myself when they started um
uh advertising on our show because you
know i want to put my money where my
mouth is i'm not going to try to tell
other people to do something that i
don't believe in
a little bit of background on noom dave
built the entire
platform on two things research and
wanting to help people
lead healthier lives through behavioral
change so that's what this is about
it's not like a diet program this is
talk getting cycle
this is getting like psychoanalyzing
your habits
and teaching you how to change your
habit your behavioral habits
they have experts health experts uh that
have master degrees in fields including
psychology integrative medicine
neuroscience
and even though they're all about
evidence-based science they're also
passionate about creating
a more empathetic approach for a
healthier life
i think it's great like that you take a
quiz on this like you do with some of
the other products yeah that we've
uh plugged a quiz um but the quiz
is really really
informative for them the questions
they're asking you get incredibly
specific
um and it just as soon as you start
answering them you can already tell like
i'm on my way
to doing something that's going to work
better for my life breaking habits
it's yeah it's it's it's really a
cognitive behavioral approach
which if you've ever been to that type
of therapy i find it incredibly
incredibly healthy and helpful it breaks
bad habits of south side it's not it
changes your relationship with food
yes and it's also not like setting like
strict rules that's the difference it's
like
it empowers you with the knowledge to
build smarter more sustainable habits
and behaviors
because everyone's different so they
customize the program based on your
personal goals
you don't have to fear ruining the whole
program if you mess up one day
they just help you get right back on
track so it's not like this
you know very strict thing that if you
it's impossible
to achieve success with it yeah i set my
goal
uh i'm trying to lose a bit of weight
and uh i answered those questions in the
quiz and noom set a very fair timeline
for me
and it's not you know one of these
fast-track things
it's slow and steady wins the race but
not so slow
that it seems an impossible an
impossibility to reach the finish line
it's like 10 minutes a day to check in
it's not like anything you know that
would take a chunk out of your day 80
of the users complete the entire program
and sixty percent of the users
lose five percent or more body weight
that's that's pretty
good man wow so anyway go to noom.com
taste bud singular n-o-o-m
dot-com slash taste bud
sign up for your trial and get
psychology-based support and motivation
to reach your goals that's n-o-o-m-noom
dot-com taste bud summertime summer time
it's grillin
season baby
[Music]
let me ask you a question uh a long time
ago like in the early 1900's
if they if i told you that there's a
service where they just
they deliver all the meats that you love
and want directly to your door
would you tell me that i was some type
of witch i would say that you were a
witch
and then if you put on top of that
grass-fed only
yeah uh and that sort of thing i would
say i don't know what you're talking
about which
you go you go walk down to the butcher
shop and you wait online
right exactly now there's something
called butcher box and they bring the
butcher
to your home in the mail in a box
not the butcher himself the the service
but the reason you go to the butch
yeah exactly uh talk about i mean you
know
look it can be hard to find 100
grass-fed
finished beef and free-range organic
chicken and heritage breed pork and wild
caught salmon
at your grocery store and sometimes you
settle for two reasons number one they
don't have it
or you pay more for it than you should
because they do have it and it's
overpriced
luckily yes luckily that's our key word
today's sponsor butcherbox believes
everyone deserves these high quality
humanely sourced meats you're mainly
sourced
and new members are gonna get bacon for
life
for free when they sign up that's how
much butcher box believes in you
and believes in their products let's be
honest out of every ad we ever do free
bacon for life
is the best selling point i've ever
heard in my entire life it lights us up
man so every month butcher box ships a
curated selection of high quality
quality meats right to your home i have
them sent to mine
man do i love it each box has 9 to 11
pounds of meat
enough for about 24 individual meals
it's packed fresh
it's shipped frozen and it's vacuum
sealed
so it stays that way which is the other
best part about this is because
you're dealing with quality you're
dealing with affordable and you're also
dealing with shelf life
this stuff stays fresh for so much
longer than what you buy at the grocery
store in your
in your refrigerator of course um
because
of the way it's sealed also talk about
hitting every
ev taking every box that everybody needs
right now coming after a long hard
financial year
of you know out of work and whatever
else you're getting quality affordable
convenience long-lasting exactly right
it's humanely raised meat
and it shakes out to about they say six
bucks a meal
which for like really high-end meat like
that you're not paying
those exorbitant like inflated prices
they even ship
have free shipping nationwide except
alaska and hawaii but we still love you
um yeah i mean you can't really beat it
back by popular demand to receive bacon
for life right now new members get bacon
for life when they sign up
also you can pick like one of their
predetermined like
butcher box packages or you can
literally customize exactly what you
want on your own
just go to butcherbox.com there are no
limits here
no limit soldiers butcherbox.com taste
buds that's a package of free bacon
in every box for the life of your
subscription when you go to
butcherbox.com
taste buds it's grilling season baby
are you going to the phones already why
not why not let's go to the phones
both are absolutely incred pimp do me a
favor scroll back up because there were
some you went by that i
okay right there right no no back down
let's start here
gramps says oh i can't choose between
the two best dishes that meat has to
offer
i want to put that up as a contender for
our retweet today
because that is a wonderful wonderful
point yeah you could you could retweet
that i don't know if you won
no no pimp i need a little creativity i
just said pimp down not to scroll he's
climbing on my leg uh
ribs are i'm sorry okay sorry
okay ready the best ribs are better than
the best fried
chicken but the average fried chicken is
better than the average ribs this is
interesting in other words
ribs are much more difficult to get
right therefore fried chicken is better
but when you do get ribs right that's a
great point
well as someone said nailed it but that
goes against you my friend because we're
saying which is better
i think it's a very good point god
didn't ask adam
i said it that's hysterical
god didn't ask adam for a piece of fried
chicken to make eve did he no he asked
for a rib
why because ribs are superior that's
good all right that's that's our lead
tweet right now
uh dude ribs all day i can understand
you might have had bad ribs but that's
because you've
got to remove the membrane before you
cook them thank you zack i should have
pointed that out
i can hear joe already if you got to do
extra it's garbage
they all think they know us very well
yeah
i'd rather [ __ ] my pants and do
cartwheels and have subpar
ribs i'm perfectly content having subpar
fried chicken
because at the end of the day at least
it's fried
what else y'all talking about fried
chicken is better sit the f
down eating some greasy ass deep fried
bucket of stomach problems
give me them ribs baby all right
i'm not into barbecue ribs no way i'm
not in the barbecue rib
i'm not into barbecue and ribs are not
really my thing
fried chicken is okay but i usually take
the skin off
because i don't enjoy that so i mean has
have you heard of a period miss
maybe something to break it up jesus
god because i don't enjoy that so only
kind of fried chicken
i really eat is like nuggets and it's
not always processed you can get
chick-fil-a nut holy jesus god okay all
right
all right i think we got she likes
chick-fil-a i think is the point
homemade ribs restaurant fried chicken
okay
interesting derosa definitely loves this
because he loves ribs because he has no
shoulders
what oh wait wait wait wait wait wait
yeah oh come on
man that go to the poll i saw it
son of a [ __ ] you've got to be kidding
me 14 000 votes
humble pie segment bada-boom 66.66
fans do us a favor when you're following
the polls don't write in the
tweets what's winning or what's losing
because
then we i just saw that and it kind of
it kind of brings it to a hall
they saw what happened they know but uh
but yeah oh oh i'm down to 66.5 now
so i'm no longer the food of the devil
did you just take you're now up
four episodes fourteen thousand three
hundred
votes and i will tell you this i really
thought this was gonna be closer
i didn't know i thought i was gonna win
last week i was surprised that we were
one percent difference between lobster
roll and crab cake
oh if this comes out now we have to do
it that way you can edit that out
okay and we'll do it that way anyway
okay um i thought
that ribs would be the
an admirable foe i i thought it'd be
closer what do you think
i thought ribs i thought ribs would win
i don't know they weren't gonna win they
were never gonna win
what do you mean they were never gonna
win it's fried chicken the whole
contingency of the south would have
voted ribs
over fried chicken so they just what are
they just out to lunch right now well i
don't know
where's this house i don't know south
are you voting south
identify yourselves oh you're telling me
the whole contingency of the south
wouldn't have said fried chicken
listen you go down south you're you're
gonna be a lot harder anybody who's
eating the rib is eating fried chicken
babe
but there's people that are eating fried
chicken that aren't eating ribs you
would do them from the get
do not pass go do not collect
did you know what i'm saying sorry [ __ ]
yesterday he said to me yesterday he
said to me
i'd have to take fried chicken oh would
you you had to take the one that you did
because i don't think i could defend
the rib you said i said joe
i can't i can't defend a rib against
fried chicken
i have to take fried chicken you said
i'll take it gladly
don't come down on me for being honest i
don't want to be a phony i want to only
i'm not coming down i love ribs
i wouldn't look pimp says it all the
time this is like food court
and sometimes that we represent a food
that we don't believe in
and i was just letting you know i
thought the rib would have been guilty i
believe in the rib
and i believe that it is superior to
fried chicken and i will stand by that
but don't come down on me for telling
you that i don't think i can defend your
stones a little bit i know you all but
i'm responding
all right well you know don't respond
with real emote you know i'm
i'm breaking you know by the way we have
not declared a winning tweet oh it's
that one that said uh the uh
the one that said hey go back up again
it was a funny one can you scroll up one
second because
if contradicting themselves was a job
joe would be the ceo
cfo and ceo yeah
no let me suck up to sal
i'll take up the sal well let's get joe
and mer and q in here too
while we're at it the uh get out of town
with that
[Laughter]
no our winner was uh the the funny one
that we laughed at
oh the rib one the adam and eve one yeah
yeah yeah
so shh currently i'd love to read a
little more of these
colonel sanders and miss louisiana are
only [ __ ] making fridge
well well what who what ribs are
superior okay
the complete complexity of flavors going
on with ribs blows the sad excuse of
food
that fried chicken is out of the water
fried chicken's not a sad excuse i mean
it's winning in the comments i don't
understand how it lost that much in the
poll
fried chicken was given to us by god
himself and ribs was a quick idea satan
had
and thought and thought this will get
him
uh where is this one ribs are no that's
not it
what was it adam didn't use a rib to
red ribs this is true it's like a chew
toy a dog chew toy
bad ribs taste like i'm chewing on
leather with barbecue sauce
but bad fried chicken is still pretty
decent fried chicken i like it
it's not pretty decent chicken okay go
to a gas station and buy the fried
chicken out of the thing
and tell me it's pretty decent fried
chicken insane
go to the gas station and buy the ribs
they don't sell them at the gas station
exactly
stop it exactly but i'll tell you this
you get a barbecue sandwich in a gas
station
it's edible it's edible tastes like
barbecue sauce who's
who's ordering a barbecue sandwich at a
gas station again down south and the
little warmers they have a pulled pork
sandwich in the bar in the gas stations
you'll find it
anyway there it is there's our winner
god didn't ask adam for a piece of fried
chicken to make eve did he know
he asked for a rib why because ribs are
superior that comes from anna
you win because it's clever not because
the ribs are better very funny at anna
i'm sorry at ah underscore capital nah96
follow anna and that's our show folks
thanks for listening this week we
appreciate it check out the clips page
if you like the show do two things
subscribe if you haven't
also like subscribe to us on itunes and
spotify follow us
on there those numbers change things
they change the algorithm
they give us a bump and we get we get
put up front more and then more people
find it
so the only way this show grows and
people are like why doesn't this have a
million subs why
this why that this is the best well if
you want to help us
you got to subscribe you got to follow
and then like tell people tell people
that you know that would enjoy it
that will help us the most follow the
taste buds clips pages leave a comment
too
leave a comment join in this is the best
part of this
podcast for me is that we interact so
much with you guys yeah i love it i love
it
thanks guys that's the show for today
we'll see you next week i still love you
babe
it's getting harder and harder to say i
love you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to them